a
la alarma de nuestro móvil nos despierta
cada mañana con nuestra huella digital
lo encendemos y empezamos a ver los
mensajes de la noche anterior empezamos
a encender apps la del tiempo para saber
qué ropa ponernos mientras nos vamos
preparando hay alarmas citas la agenda
digital nos está haciendo nuestra
jornada cogemos el coche y con el gps
nos saltamos los atascos y llegamos a
nuestra oficina donde nuestro día se
desenvuelve entre ordenadores cables
máquinas tecnología que nos hacen la
vida más fácil
nuestra vida ya es digital
uno de los sectores que ha vivido una de
las mayores disrupciones tecnológicas es
el sector de la banca solo la primera
mitad del 2018 las fintech invirtieron
más de 41 billones de euros e innovación
tecnológica todo para digitalizar la
relación entre los bancos y sus clientes
vissum paypal transferencias desde el
móvil ya todo lo hacemos desde casa hace
cuánto que no vais a una sucursal
bancaria dentro de poco aún más a través
de nuestro rostro o nuestra voz con la
biometría vamos incluso a poder pagar
tal cual sin un teléfono móvil dentro de
nada vamos a tener una identidad digital
que nos va a permitir mandar dinero a
cualquier persona del mundo y sin
comisiones y todo esto para que pues
para hacernos la vida más fácil a
nosotros a las personas más afortunadas
en 2009 conocían rita
anguita vivía en un slam debajo de un
puente nueva delhi con sus padres que
eran alcohólicos
por el día en rita mendigaba intentando
conseguir unas pocas rupias para comprar
comida y alcohol para sus padres con
bastante esfuerzo conseguimos que sus
padres la dejasen participar en un
programa para 10 niñas cuyo objetivo era
rehabilitar las sacarlas de la calle
sin embargo cuando habían pasado seis
meses del programa nos llama su padre y
nos dice bueno os dais doce mil rupias
aproximadamente doscientos euros o nos
devolverán rita porque esa es la
cantidad que nos acaba de ofrecer una
mafia de explotación sexual por ella
[Aplausos]
en ese momento bueno fue el primer gran
dilema al que me enfrenté cuando llegué
a india como cooperante dispuesto a
cambiar el mundo
en ese momento podía cambiar la vida de
anne rita por doscientos mil euros euros
pero la teoría era clara no hay que
pagarlos mientras en corrupción es
mañana te van a pedir 200 más el dinero
de la ong se nos acabarían en días pero
claro no pagando los suponía que esta
niña acabaría prostituida y que además
los seis meses que llevamos trabajando
con ella no hubiesen servido de nada
dinero tirada a la basura que dirían los
donantes
juzgo era otra de las niñas de la casa
de acogida tenía una mirada y una
sonrisa
tremendamente impactantes sin embargo su
cuerpo estaba quemado los niños de la
calle son tremendamente vulnerables
tienen muchísimo miedo de los adultos y
cuesta mucho conocer su identidad
conocer su pasado tardamos meses en
hacer la rehabilitación psicosocial pero
descubrimos porque se había quemado se
había prendido fuego a ella misma porque
quería dar asco a los hombres incluidos
su padre que abusaron de ella
sexualmente cada noche en las estaciones
de tren
diez niñas pasaron por el programa diez
historias reales cada cual más
impactante solo diez de los más de diez
millones de niños y niñas que viven en
las calles de india sólo diez de los
entre 100 y 150 millones de niños que
hay en nuestro mundo hoy en la calle que
deambulan entre ciudades entre
estaciones huyendo de magias huyendo de
muchas veces sus propios padres millones
de invisibles que intentan subsistir en
la fortuna de esa invisibilidad para no
caer en los infiernos de la esclavitud
de la mafia de los abusos
y no solo son invisibles porque no les
veamos son invisibles porque para la
sociedad no existen
no hablamos sólo de niños en situación
de calle a esto hay que sumarle más de
70 millones de personas refugiadas más
de 20 millones de víctimas de trata y
los tantos millones de personas que
nacieron en zonas remotas quizá el lugar
equivocado donde precisamente por eso no
fueron registrados al nacer hablamos de
más del 20 por ciento de la población
mundial que no tienen un documento de
identidad que les acredite como
ciudadanos con derechos os habéis
planteado alguna vez que ese documento
de identidad ese papel plastificado que
tiene vuestros datos de identidad que
tenéis todos vosotros en vuestras
carteras es lo que os hace visibles ante
la sociedad imaginaros por unos segundos
vuestra vida sin este trozo de papel
pues bien han rita y cus book y las
otras ocho niñas que pasaron por nuestro
programa fueron las visibilizaron para
mí esa invisibilidad y fueron la
motivación por la que dejé mi trabajo en
banca de inversión en irlanda para
quedarme en yendo y trabajar en
innovación social
en un mundo en el que la tecnología está
reformando todo está solucionando todos
nuestros problemas incluso aquellos que
es que si lo piensas no son problemas yo
me preguntaba cómo puede ser que la
tecnología no haya ayudado a acabar con
todo este sinsentido cómo puede ser que
todos los sectores han sido
transformados completamente por la
tecnología digital izándose para llegar
a sus clientes de manera más rápida más
barata más efectiva sabiendo quiénes son
saliendo sus necesidades cómo puede ser
que el sector social que tiene al
cliente más vulnerable con las
necesidades más absolutas y que si
tienen que ser solucionadas de manera
urgente siga trabajando de una forma tan
precaria
fue ahí cuando descubrí lo que para mí
es el primer gran reto del sector social
y es precisamente hacer visibles a estos
invisibles el tema del registro si no
podemos cuantificar los problemas si no
sabemos quiénes los padecen cómo vamos a
realmente solucionarlos cómo vamos a
atender de esas ongs bien descubrí que
las ongs trabajamos prácticamente con
papel y lápiz que después ponemos los
datos en unos excel en el mejor de los
casos en bases de datos más o menos
sofisticadas pero claro la rotación de
personal de cooperantes hace que muchas
veces esas bases de datos se pierdan
también con el tiempo y además si las
personas con las que trabajamos no
tienen un documento de identidad como
realmente sabemos que son quienes dicen
ser soy bien una persona a recibir un
servicio y mañana vuelve y dice llamarse
de otra manera probablemente volvamos a
darle el servicio y además les
registraremos una vez más
me empecé a preguntar que usábamos en
banca para gestionar las identidades la
biometría y fue así como decidimos
desarrollar un sistema de reconocimiento
biométrico que hoy permite a manejes y a
gobiernos identificar con altísima
fiabilidad a estos colectivos invisibles
y además gestionar sus datos en bases de
datos seguras eficientes y hábiles
seguras porque además es muy importante
la seguridad de estos datos hablamos de
datos muy sensibles de identidades los
script amos y lo subimos a la nube
precisamente para eso
con la biometría podemos registrar a
millones de niños como juzgo como an
rita que hoy están en delhi pero mañana
tienen miedo cogen un tren y estarán en
mumbai que hoy dicen llamarse an rita
pero a lo mejor mañana el trabajador
social de mumbai le dicen que son blanca
por miedo es lógico con esta tecnología
podemos protegerles mejor podemos tener
datos mucho más fiables y eficientes
para tomar mejores decisiones y esto es
lo que estamos haciendo precisamente ya
en india en una red de más de 80 ongs
que trabajan conectadas y que desde 2013
han identificado ya más de 300.000 niños
estamos ahora escalando la solución
también a países como senegal y sierra
leona gracias al trabajo y colaboración
con otras entidades pues bien con
biometría descubrí la solución al tema
del registro del sector pero claro mi
mente
bueno pues obsesionada por la eficiencia
probablemente por mi pasado en el banco
me llevó a descubrir un segundo reto que
tiene el sector social y es cómo
garantizamos que el dinero llega como
además lo optimizamos al máximo cómo
podemos hacer esa trazabilidad tan
perfecta
en el banco con el dinero cómo podemos
exprimir cada euro optimizarlo igual que
hacían banca de inversión pues bien
encontrar la solución en 2017 en otra
tecnología en block sing
si internet vino para digitalizar la
comunicación y transformó por completo
cómo nos comunicamos blog se ha venido
para digitalizar activos y para
intercambiarlos digitalmente y
transformar completamente cómo lo
hacemos por ejemplo el dinero con blogs
en podemos digitalizarlo y trazar en
todo momento dónde está
pero no sólo el dinero por ejemplo un
contrato con block change podemos
garantizar que unos fondos salen de una
cuenta bancaria solo y únicamente cuando
se cumplen ciertos hitos ciertos
contratos como os podréis imaginar los
bancos están invirtiendo millones están
en esta tecnología sin embargo es que no
se me ocurre un sector para el que la
trazabilidad del dinero sea más
importante que el sector social que está
puramente basado en la confianza os
imaginais recibir un sms cuando diez
euros quedó mastica una ong hace seis
meses se acaban de ejecutar y saber
exactamente en qué y más aún os
imagináis sabe el impacto social que han
tenido esos diez euros porque además una
persona o varias sean beneficio de sus
servicios y pueden validarlo con la
tecnología no es maravilloso pues bien
hoy la tecnología lo permite y por eso
estamos desarrollando una plataforma
digital en blogs en un ecosistema el
bien común para que precisamente
organizaciones puedan gestionar de
manera transparente sus proyectos y los
individuos y las organizaciones que los
financian que invierten en sus proyectos
puedan tener la garantía de todo esto
pues bien como habéis visto la biometría
puede solucionar el primer gran reto del
registro y block change puede ayudarnos
a garantizar que la solidaridad llega y
que se gestiona de manera más eficiente
pues bien llegamos al tercer y último
gran reto con el que me encontré quién
financia todo esto
estamos dispuestos
invertir en innovación tecnológica en el
entorno social es claro como cualquier
sector
hay que asumir riesgos estamos
dispuestos los donantes a asumir esos
riesgos y los grandes fondos
filantrópicos las empresas a través de
su rss
pues la respuesta con mi experiencia es
que tristemente todavía no y es muy
frustrante quien arriesga no gana y
estamos hablando de ganar la batalla al
hambre a la desnutrición a la trata al
trabajo infantil llevamos años
intentando solucionar todos esos
problemas y no los hemos solucionado no
es de cajón que hay que innovar
todos los sectores se han transformado
completamente con la tecnología si todo
es como la ciencia en los bancos han
conseguido grandísimos avances gracias a
la tecnología hoy podemos viajar a la
luna podemos hacer una transferencia
desde el móvil estoy convencida
convencidísima de que podemos acabar con
el trabajo infantil
sin embargo si no dejamos a las ongs a
las personas las organizaciones que
estamos al lado de esos problemas que
los conocemos perfectamente que tenemos
las ideas para solucionarlos invertir en
tecnología invertir en innovación social
desde luego no lo vamos a poder
conseguir
hay quien dice que la solución está en
el emprendimiento social y efectivamente
yo estoy de acuerdo en que hacen falta
modelos de negocio modelos de
sostenibilidad para estos proyectos pero
hay problemas para los cuales la
solución no tiene un modelo de negocio
por lo menos no a corto plazo sencillo y
ahí es donde está la filantropía ahí es
donde debe debemos estar ahí está la
solidaridad porque una empresa
probablemente nunca habéis estado en
aquel slam en nueva delhi nunca habéis
estado al lado y hoy es identificado
esos problemas de quxian rita porque
nunca hubiese estado trabajando en un
programa de rehabilitación de sólo diez
niñas un programa sin ningún modelo de
negocio ahí solo está la solidaridad una
empresa probablemente nunca hubiese
pagado los 200 euros que nosotros si
pagamos por andriy está para una empresa
en un riesgo muy grande para la
filantropía no lo es porque saldrá una
niña de ser prostituida siempre tiene
sentido y no se puede hablar ni de
inversión ni de riesgo de ninguna de
esas palabras trabajo para llevar la
tecnología más avanzada a donde
realmente más se necesita y luego con
modelos de sostenibilidad sin embargo
eso sucede mientras conseguimos que no
haya más niñas como amrita y puso en la
calle lo que sí que tengo claro es que
una vida nunca tiene precio y que cuando
hablamos de solucionar problemas de
salvar vidas como la de kursk en
momentos tan difíciles en situaciones
tan complejas no hay más modelo de
negocio que la solidaridad gracias
[Aplausos]